en términos prácticos Cuál es la
relevancia de que se pueda o no aumentar
el límite de la deuda en Estados Unidos
y qué escenario enfrenta el país si no
hay aumento
Bueno lo que dice la Secretario del
tesoro es que sería una catástrofe ella
ella le pone un nombre calamidad
calamity pero realmente ese día en
castellano una catástrofe económica el
dólar pudiera caer a menos de la mitad
de su valor con lo cual por supuesto
todas las importaciones a los Estados
Unidos se duplicarían de precio y sería
este la primera vez en la historia de
los Estados Unidos en donde este país
entra en default entra en sensación de
pagos que es una cosa que nosotros los
países latinoamericanos Quizás lo vemos
de una manera sin importancia Argentina
Cada diez años entran sensación de pagos
otros países lo hacen y no pasa
absolutamente nada se renuncia de la
deuda etcétera En este caso no porque el
eje de la economía mundial el país que
más exporta y más importa es Estados
Unidos y después china están casi cabeza
a nivel mundial y es la moneda de
reserva
Bueno ahora hay dos Discúlpeme por favor
continúe Bueno hay dos escuelas de
pensamiento sobre este problema una es
que se va a resolver como siempre se ha
resuelto mediante una discusión entre
los líderes de los dos partidos porque
nadie imagina que puede ser puede ser
tan irresponsables como para auto
infligirse una derrota tan grande una
derrota económica tan grande que sería
absolutamente gratis porque no hay
ninguna razón para no hay ninguna razón
sustancial para preocuparse por la
economía norteamericana Pero hay otra
escuela de pensamiento que es más
pesimista y que tengo que contárselos a
ustedes Aunque realmente a mí me da
mucha pena que esto vaya a suceder que
dice que los republicanos están
realmente tratando de que los Estados
Unidos entre en en default para ayudar a
Putin a que derrote a Ucrania porque
ellos imaginan que haciendo que la
economía norteamericana colapse o venga
una catástrofe financiera de alguna
forma ellos van a lograr que Putin este
logre derrotar lo cual no tiene ninguna
conexión pero eso es lo que está en la
cabeza de muchos republicanos en el
congreso como
[Música]
y otras personas que son abiertamente
defienden a Vladimir Putin entonces la
componente de la Guerra de Ucrania está
pendiente en esta negociación que es una
cosa inédita nunca en la historia de los
Estados Unidos una parte del Congreso
había intentado destruir la economía del
propio país que ellos representan es la
primera vez bueno y cuáles son las
principales demandas de los republicanos
hay algunas en las que baiden podría
acceder
no creo porque fíjate lo único que ellos
han pedido es que se recorte el gasto es
justamente en los veteranos de guerra
que es una cosa prácticamente Sagrada
para los Estados Unidos Eso nunca lo van
a aceptar un presidente norteamericano
jamás va a permitir que se recorte los
gastos de atención médica y de pensiones
a los veteranos de la guerra eso eso
planteado Y eso es lo que están pidiendo
a ellos Entonces ellos han pedido cosas
deliberadamente imposibles de conceder y
lo que dice el presidente biden es que
cualquier negociación presupuestaria se
debe realizar cuando se negoció el
presupuesto lo cual es el peor Grullo
sin embargo los republicanos han metido
las dos cosas juntas que no tienen
ningún sentido técnico porque el
parlamento negocia el el presupuesto más
adelante en comisiones de ambos partidos
y ahí hay una pelea como se diría en
Sudamérica a cuchillo pero llega a un
acuerdo sin embargo los republicanos
intentan de alguna forma obtener
concesiones presupuestarias fuera de la
discusión presupuestaria y ese es el
problema que tenemos en este momento el
partido republicano moderno el que está
en el poder en este momento no sigue con
las reglas tradicionales de la política
hay muchos miembros que no son políticos
ni son abogados ni son economistas ni
son hombres de negocio mujeres de
negocio son simplemente activi stas que
muchas veces no han ni siquiera
terminado la secundaria y están en los
principales puestos de poder de el
partido republicano una cosa es jamás se
había visto desde la época de George
Washington